como se puede beneficiar causa justa con
esta aparición en una de las revistas
más importantes del mundo
muchas gracias un placer saludarlos
también a ustedes pues realmente yo creo
que tanto cristina como yo simbolizamos
aparte de nuestro trabajo y nuestra
trayectoria el esfuerzo de una lucha
colectiva llevada a cabo por el
movimiento causa justa que surge al seno
de la mesa por la vida y la salud de las
mujeres y creo que este reconocimiento
lo que hace justamente es poner el
reflector en este país sobre la
estrategia que utilizamos sobre la
manera como convertimos un tema que es
tan controversial en una oportunidad de
un diálogo democrático argumentado
tranquilo pausado y definitivamente ese
reflector a mi modo de ver tiene como
dos consecuencias muy importantes para
el movimiento la primera servir como un
faro para otros países del mundo donde
la situación de penalización es crítica
grave o incluso donde existen amenazas
de retroceso como en los eeuu pero
también para nosotras porque reafirma lo
que hemos dicho y es el valor que tiene
en este siglo una lucha como la que
hemos librado por la libertad
reproductiva para todas las niñas
adolescentes y mujeres del país usted
habla de un faro para otros países y de
hecho time también resalta que la labor
de ustedes da esperanza a los derechos
reproductivos en eeuu donde precisamente
la corte suprema podría prohibir el
aborto profundicemos en este tema que
ustedes ya mencionó como toma que la
revista estadounidense reconozca el
trabajo de causa justa precisamente en
este contexto político de allí
pues me parece increíble que haya que
exista digamos este reconocimiento a los
feminismos del sur global yo creo que
los feminismos en américa latina' además
tenemos una tradición de encuentro de
acumulación política de compartir
estrategias
ideas formas de discutir de movilizarnos
en las calles con siempre de manera
pacífica digamos y abriendo
conversaciones democráticas entonces lo
tomo como un reconocimiento a la
centralidad que tiene este tema de la
libertad en dos sentidos uno en tener
democracias más sólidas y más firmes y
democracias y sociedades mejores que
reconozcan la ciudadanía plena a las
mujeres yo creo que pues en este momento
que puede ser muy lamentable para la
historia de eeuu porque imagínense
ustedes que un buen día se despierten y
les digan que ya no pueden votar
eso les podría pasar a las mujeres en
eeuu sin embargo la conquista de los
derechos que es muy importante en el
plano legal también ocurre en el plano
de lo que nosotros llamamos la
legitimidad social y estoy segura que
las mujeres en eeuu son conscientes de
que tienen ese derecho a que se les
respete su libertad reproductiva y vamos
de aquí en adelante intercambiar desde
el sur hacia el norte estrategias para
ayudar a que este retroceso no cobre las
vidas de mujeres como realmente es lo
que sucede en este tipo de situaciones
bueno y también también destaca la labor
que ustedes lideraron para despenalizar
el aborto en medio de un país
profundamente
religioso cuáles fueron los principales
retos que enfrentaron y cómo los
vencieron muy brevemente
pues la verdad es que tanto la iglesia
como los grupos anti derechos estuvieron
bastante silenciosos en esta
conversación y sobre todo se centraron
en trabas de carácter procesal y creo
que los vencimos justamente con eso con
argumentos con presencia con
transparencia con trabajo pedagógico con
presencia en las calles y con una
demanda presentada con sólidos
argumentos que hoy nos permiten estar a
la vanguardia de américa latina y del
mundo con este fallo histórico bueno
anacristina felicitaciones por la
aparición en los 100 más influyentes del
mundo y gracias por estar aquí en france
muchísimas gracias gracias por esas
felicitaciones también nosotros seguimos
con más información en france 24